foreign
[Music]
have you been compromising day in and
day out
when no compromise is necessary
and I'll go one further where no
compromise should ever be expected
it is time to match intensive
every single one of you watching or
listening right now is to flip a switch
in your head where you will make those
sons of embarrassed that they
ever even thought of asking that
compliment
imagine the founding fathers looking
down and going what the are you
people doing you're talking about the
same people that rail against
misinformation
platform Adam Schiff this case needs to
be blown up the ATF needs to be held
accountable why can we not condemn evil
Behavior
[Music]
hello mug club and all you strange
animals out there
we've been hard at work with our friends
at Rumble to bring you the first Network
controlled bike creators and two of the
biggest giants in this industry are
joining forces under the same umbrella
no more censorship no more big Tech
dependents no more one-sided contracts
the time for an open honest and
transparent network has arrived the time
for a network controlled by the creators
has arrived the time for a network that
allows creators to focus on their
audience has arrived if you're signing
up for Mud Club today use promo code
re-platforming for a free fight like
hell t-shirt join us in that fight we
didn't seek this out guys we didn't look
for the extra work of trying to start a
network we wanted to do a show we wanted
to make people laugh we wanted to
educate and entertain them and try to
help save our country but so many of you
weren't being served it was all about
scam advertising dishonest tactics
censorship playing ball with people that
don't share your values and we couldn't
stand idly by while that happened they
want to cancel every one of you and
every one of us but because of you
because of Mud Club they can't touch us
let the re-platforming begin
[Music]
made him uncancelable welcome the
strange animal himself
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
um
I have
all right welcome to the re-platforming
conference we have some members of the
press and friends here uh thanks for
coming out we'll be taking some
questions from them later
but that was a self-important intro but
thank you guys for putting it together
I never feel comfortable with that I
wish I were a rapper
[Laughter]
so uh look just a few minutes we'll be
making some major announcements
regarding the future of mug club and
it's widening to a full-fledged Network
powered by Rumble and what I mean by
that is mug Club if you go to latter.com
now one portal and it's a network to
many different creators uh some of whom
will announce today and more to come so
we have announcements regarding new
shows uh new types of content new ways
to impact the country this increasingly
silly place and the tyrannical platforms
of big Tech but first let get into this
a little bit re-platforming
is the title here for a reason
and uh because of all these
announcements and the people from whom
you're about to hear
re-platforming is a story here about
what's been lost what's been risked
really what's been taken from people and
what's starting today we will all
actively begin to regain and before that
my club's been around for such a long
time that it kind of occurred to me for
some of the folks new here I haven't
done a great job in explaining to you
what mug Club is what phase one at least
has been up until now before we get to
the new announcements it's a simple
concept mug Club
we bleed so you don't have to
we've had people come up and say Hey you
know I wish I could say some of these
things that you know you guys can say on
there but but I'll get i'll get fired
from my job I don't want you to get
fired from your job but when you join up
when you give us your dollar
we have to be able to say what it is
that you can't say otherwise we're
stealing from you if we play ball with
big Tech if we decide to take your
dollar but then say we got to make tens
of millions of dollars off YouTube ad
Revenue we're screwing you
so mug Club is exactly what has allowed
us all of us to remain completely
independent since 2016. before that
online Revenue was generated by ads okay
some inside baseball here I knew back
then in order to maintain that I would
have to make compromises YouTube
Facebook they kept telling us what kind
of content we were permitted to post
what kind of creators they would be
happy to work with and exactly what kind
of people what kind of conservatives
would be put in the corner
I couldn't stomach it then I can't
stomach it now and no one here can and
because of Mud Club because of you we
don't have to
give you some history because a mug Club
when NBC Universal Vox CNN try to
de-platform all of us meaning us and you
we survived the Vox apocalypse YouTube
Google said hey you're not going to make
another dime off ads and because of you
mug club we said fine viewers like you
you know how PBS says that but really
they made another Grant more money
please
because of Mud Club with zero ad Revenue
we were able to host the single most
viewed individually viewed I should say
election stream of 2020 and because of
Mud Club not being beholden to Big text
advertising or the guidelines we were
able to cover the voting dumps as they
happened the boarded up polling stations
as they happened the corrupt early
calling of States as they happened and
the gaslighting of you from the media
and big tech for believing Your Lying
Eyes and lying ears completely
demonetized we can keep fighting because
of Mud Club and when we were banned by
the way from covering the midterm
elections 2024 kicked off YouTube Just a
week before happenstance YouTube and
Google
because of Mud Club we broadcast the
single largest individual election live
stream to occur on any other platform
outside of YouTube doing it through
Rumble in the history of the internet
completely demonetized we can keep
fighting and growing because of my club
because of my club when the entire world
went crazy and locked down due to the
China virus and you were going stir
crazy with nowhere to go and even
conservative hosts were suspending their
broadcasting or doing it from their
basement with a webcam we were able to
be right here with you and instead for
an entire month broadcast to a days with
mug Club quarantine the entire staff
right here from this very Studio because
of mug club during that same time we
were able to introduce whistleblowers
like Dr Peter McCullough other
practicing biologists to the world the
very first week of lockdown
and when we were suspended for daring to
question the status quo we survived
completely demonetized we can keep
fighting because of Mud Club and because
of Mud Club when on the very same day
we'll be making some announcements here
today
but think of this the very same day Alex
Jones was de-platformed from YouTube
Google Facebook Twitter Apple Spotify
along with a warning that anyone hosting
him would be suspended themselves and
many of his so-called friends abandoned
him we hosted him immediately and we
wore that suspension with honor
completely demonetized we can keep
fighting because of my club and because
we did and because so many of you
watched and joined YouTube reversed
course and allowed Alex Jones to appear
on programs just as a guest moving
forward he just wasn't allowed to host a
program of his own they said and so
because of mug club we immediately
allowed Alex Jones to fill and host for
this very show
[Laughter]
and we wore our immediate suspension
with pride
completely demonetized we could keep
fighting and growing because of mug Club
mug Club is why we were able to cover
the lied about origins of covid-19 and
the potential side effects of the
experimental mRNA injection while it was
strictly forbidden before before it was
allowed
and Mud Club is why when even nearly not
nearly every mainstream conservative
that we can think of said that we lived
through the most secure election of our
light lifetime which you can count on
one hand exceptions we were able to
cover exactly why that was verifiably
irrefutably untrue
while it was strictly again forbidden to
do so on YouTube and Facebook
until YouTube just officially announced
that it'll be allowed
and that's the most important part
something that maybe we take for granted
and you take for granted when I say it's
you it's not just a buzzword
it's precisely because of you mug club
that these things are now even
permissible
on these big Tech platforms
if you heard that voice there's some
foreshadowing son of a
mug Club is the tip of the spear mug
Club Can't for all of its flaws and
there are many Gerald
Muk Club cannot be bought sold or
bargained with that's the reputation
take it or leave it and when an entity
like that when an entity comprised of
nothing more than all of you all of you
you are who we serve you are to whom we
are beholden and you're the driver of
billions of views and listeners
cumulatively
the people who want to silence you who
want to dictate what you hear who hate
everything you stand for well guess what
they can't de-platform us all
they'd have no one left to do business
with
so now as a full-fledged Network and the
announcements we're about to make and
continue to make mug Club is bigger than
them mug Club is why we don't need them
and that's why all of us here are
genuinely free you mug Club are the
reason that they are scared
and they should be
because where do you see what's next
this was just phase one
[Music]
hey everyone this is Stephen Crowder
what we're talking about is Free Speech
[Music]
Crowder it's very
it's very offensive yeah thanks for
having me Stephen
[Music]
garbage ass
for fire
I guarantee you multiple people right
here then right now what how can you
guarantee that people call me the Tony
Robbins of assassinations
[Music]
all right oh
and I'm gonna drown every last damn name
a baby that I come across whether it's a
runoff walk off get my baby off I I I'll
go off when you leave
[Music]
my girl wanted me to run an errand and
she goes
take my bike but it has a basket on the
front of it I was like
I'm gonna walk you know I just feel like
I'm a target for homophobic Bandits yeah
most serial killers are white but you
know why to be a serial killer takes a
lot of effort it's like a full-time job
black crime is just quick and simple you
know that show The First 48 they have a
new one the first 48 seconds it's just
black crimes
[Music]
oh I've never heard the n-word so much
in my life and I had a racist
grandmother and if you're trying to take
our guns 1776 will commence again
[Music]
foreign
so uh before we get to some of the new
announcements new shows new divisions
that we're creating here and again you
can go to latoscredit.com mug Club enter
in the promo code re-platforming you to
fight like hell shirt I want to give the
microphone over to some people who've
played a role here at mug club and
growing this place and uh are now going
to be playing a bigger role so first uh
this is a man right here with a resume
that you rarely find in the I mean
quote-unquote conservative movement so
through the last decades he's had roles
and film television he's hosted shows he
sold out theaters
um
but with Brian count let me let me tell
you a little bit about what he lost
because that's what re-platforming is
about
and the era of The metoo Witch Hunt when
people are being false false accused
left and right he not only had a top 10
podcast in the sports world
he Not only was a central character on
one of ABC's Hallmark shows his role was
so popular he was given his own spin-off
on ABC in prime time
smear campaign later he lost all of it
the term canceled doesn't even cover it
but now he's ready to let his freak flag
fly and Beyond being in third chair uh
and appearing in sketches which he's
done he will be launching his weekly
show on September 1st the Brian Callan
show but mug Club will also be producing
Brian callan's next stand-up comedy
special more on that in a minute one
where he can finally pull no punches
show the world everything that he truly
is again because of my club so please
welcome to the team part-timer to
full-timer Mr Brian Callum
[Applause]
yeah
there you go
thank you thank you my fellow Americans
thank you Stephen listen let's get
serious there are a lot of bad ideas out
there that have very real consequences
for our democracy it is no longer safe
to speak the truth it is no longer safe
to even question the edicts handed down
from The Establishment Kings The
Gatekeepers today will crush you
financially they will censor you they
will de-platform you they will label you
they will vilify you the rules grow more
specific weirder and more plentiful by
the day
as I speak you'll even be punished if
you stand with traditional beliefs and
values
well
Welcome to the pushback
over see that see that a lot of people
over here you can't see them should see
that how you guys doing in the
nosebleeds they can't hear me all right
Stephen and the louder with Crowder
family have been battling it out on
their own for a long time now well I am
excited to be part of an ever expanding
group of Misfits and Comics that have
had enough and want to join the fight
pushback isn't just about fighting bad
ideas with better ideas it's not just
about shouting into a microphone we're
here to change hearts and minds and we
are going to do it the way Stephen has
always done it with humor satire wit and
maybe a little screaming into the
microphone you know what I'm saying a
little screen a little bit yeah a little
anger once in a while goes a long way we
are going to entertain you so hard and
so often that you can't help but hear
and see the truth you can't help it
there is no one in the conservative
space putting back on the left's
terrible ideas with Stephen's level of
funny no one's even in the same area
code so when Stephen asked me to join
the family I was like where do I sign up
this is must see pushback we are an army
of funny people with a point of view
funny with a philosophy we are not your
grandpa's conservative show we ain't the
strict chaperones standing in the corner
telling everyone not to dance the party
is here this is where you get to laugh
learn and be heard and I am excited to
be part of it all
yes
it was supposed to be it's supposed to
be it's supposed to be done no you're
good but there were supposed to be dubs
I wanted to release stuff where are the
dogs
I want a dog they're a dubbed over there
[Laughter]
see it actually does it says Graphics
confetti
he wasn't lying uh again the promo code
is oh there we go
yeah and we appreciate that we have
members of the press and family here we
uh it was one of those things we
couldn't do this at a venue because you
know people might shoot me
and this and this next guy again this is
before the announcements that we're
making
um and I'm incredibly excited for some
of those but this is a guy uh
all right he's gonna get mad at me
because this is going to be a little
sappy
um
okay I'm just trying to think if I
should even say this because he's going
to be like nah this kid's this kid's a
fruitcake
okay I can't say that I can't say that I
can't say that there's no way I can say
this
there's no way I can say that oh okay
all right I got it
and then I'll talk about the comedies
but you're doing your stand-up special
when are you filming that to Brian
whenever you tell me well that's not how
it works I'm developing it all right so
this next guy I'm just gonna go for it
they say never meet they apologize in
advance they say never meet your Heroes
and it's an odd feeling meeting one of
your professional Idols I don't mean
idolatry I mean professional Idols just
before you guys some of you guys get
upset here uh and actually being in a
position where you have anything to
offer them
of value I've had two comedy heroes in
my life and you've heard me say this
back since 2014. Norm Macdonald and Nick
depalo
now in every industry there's often a
person who people think is the man right
the person who gets the accolades or the
push as it's called and some
entertainment Industries and then behind
the scenes there's the guy there's the
actual guy and when you ask any of that
industry's peers they would flat out
tell you oh oh yeah he's the guy
in the world of stand-up comedy for
decades that guy is Nick depaolo Nick
depalo is not only one of the longest
standing veterans in the industry he's
the guy who's some of the world's most
famous comedians still call when they
need help writing jokes to this day to
give you an idea
when Joe Rogan went through his conflict
with Carlos Mencia back in the day and I
was watching from from Montreal his
primary problem was with unoriginality
and you can go back and watch this clip
he talked about how difficult it was to
write truly excellent original comedy
and when he listed examples of the gold
standard
of people who inspired him he listed two
people Dave Chappelle and Nick depaolo
Nick's fatal flaw is that he was just
never able to keep his mouth shut
he's he's Nick Nepal has always reviled
the left political correctness or what
we know today is cancel culture the
stories of him going off on some
entitled feminist who made the heir of
hecklingham at The Comedy Cellar in New
York City they're still discussed
they're echoed through the halls of that
club to this day
he was canceled fired really before that
term exists from his own radio show at
SiriusXM when a latinx professor at
Fresno State was Joy tweeting that
Barbara Bush had died Nick depalo did
what he does best and he wrote I don't
know I hope he's he wrote this tweet in
response uh
dear future School shooters please
confine yourselves to college campuses
specifically faculty lounges at Berkeley
Fresno State
it was funny then and it's funny now
and he was fired and he never changed
this is not a man just to be clear who
kept his head down made his bones and
then decided to come out of the closet
as some right-wing lunatic for clicks
this man doesn't own a closet door and
he has always been a right-wing lunatic
while other people in the industry right
they would seek his advice from behind
the scenes and I'll say this because he
will never say this okay
people will seek his advice behind
closed doors and maybe there's some
folks out there who you may watch who
maybe lift some of his stylings from
back in Boston softening it for a
mainstream audience this guy was being
turned down for roles from venues he's
had shows canceled he was even punched
in the face at a comedy club by a
lesbian Broad and Birkenstocks
the black guy
his mouth shut and the reason that this
is the re-platforming conference is
because this is a story not even about
what was lost but what was taken from
someone
and what at this moment in time for the
first time can be regained and will be
regained and because of all this he was
called of course look before you were
racist sexist homophobic you name it for
his entire career here at mug club and
myself personally we call him the
funniest man alive Nick depaolo
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Kevin
and the T-shirt was not my idea what is
this Ariana Grande
you look good yeah
great to be here seriously uh you came
along at a good time uh my wife has a
Coke problem
a lot of bills
got a dog with cataracts Stephen calls
me where do I sign up
now I'm here obviously for a few reasons
first of all uh all the jobs dried up in
the Garment District
too too old to join a militia and I was
kicked out of Oprah's Book Club that fat
I blame half the on her and nobody
does but she started this
anti-white horse I'm trying I'm
very nervous big day for me
my career hinges on this kid
uh I'm part of my club honestly because
it's the only source for the truth right
now as far as letting people know what's
being done to this country and what deep
we're in thanks to the leftist
elitist uh scum that make up both the
mainstream media and that vast criminal
Enterprise known as the Democrat Party
uh I want to kill him uh
whether it's confronting brainwashed
students on a college campus calling out
politicians on their uh no one
has been doing it longer and better than
I feel the city here Stephen Crowder
please more Applause for crowded
thank you
it's crowded right is it Crowder all
right
uh mug Club gives you the uh unvarnished
truth but it does uh Jesus my eyes are
going halfway through this thing
but it's like trying to read the
ingredients on a protein bar the
font
uh
but it doesn't
it anyway it's
it's where you can get the latest news
opinions
um but what makes it different is he
backs it up with facts and all while
you're laughing your ass off at the same
time you can't find it anywhere other
than here in MSNBC
[Laughter]
I noticed that that uh crowded and Mud
Club were being
platforms that I despise on
social media YouTube Facebook
um Latino housewives.org
and of course that uh you know that
human feces that mix up Twitter
um I I was thinking to myself this guy
must be doing something right to be
perceived as such a threat to these
stalinous loving stains
it is
no c word here so uh when I was
approached by mug Club to enlist in this
Army I was like it was a no-brainer what
I get to say exactly what I want no
matter how offensive this is with
without being canceled or worrying about
offending these um
bedwetting thumb and sucking
leftists that
and without being a canceled on the spot
uh so I said put me in coach I'm ready
to play so
sure I have two bad hips and I'm a week
away from this
I'm strong
you
I was in here nothing
here's your real muck Club empty the
fact that crowd uh has almost six
million Subs on his platform run by
people who detest everything he myself
and all the other shows on this network
stand for speaks to how powerful mug
Club has become
um I I just gotta say stand up
um I'm a stand-up comic and the freedom
I get
being a part of this is It's Priceless
and Stephen I want to thank you again
and Long Live mug Club everybody
foreign
[Applause]
you really must be close with Colin
Quinn that's a prompter issue
enjoying twins
40 feet
uh and by the way Nick's show is still
going on uh our show uh a lot of Scott
is going to be coming back uh Monday
August 14th uh unless we were hard at
work with a lot behind the scenes and
Nick your show is Monday through
Thursday
5 p.m Eastern so you can still watch
that CNN
so let me get into now
um some of the new developments here and
these are some major announcements
they've taken a long time and I I can't
thank the people behind the scenes
enough and all of this is truly
supported by you and if you watch the
show you know there are very few
sponsorship placements we don't generate
ad Revenue like we've talked about on
YouTube and big Tech platforms so I want
to be clear here
this is Mud Club is a business
um and that's important because
unfortunately there's far too much
non-profit influence in the conservative
sphere that isn't beholden to you these
people are appointed not necessarily
elected so mug Club is a business run by
you but it's never been just business
I've heard that phrase a lot
if that's what it was we wouldn't be
announcing this next part it doesn't
make sense from a business standpoint
but it certainly does from a pivotally
important for our country point of view
investigative journalism it's largely
dead
why
and we've identified some problems out
there and we're doing our best to solve
them that's what this is about too why
is it largely dead because it's not a
money-making endeavor
in a world where journalism is only as
valuable as its clicks or how it
exploits the algorithm that day telling
a story from scratch is hard educating
an audience from square one is difficult
now finding a story or in the case of
subterfuge so pervasive it runs so deep
that no one even knows about it in the
public meaning that you are effectively
creating that story
in the public view it's almost
impossible
and this is a problem by the way that
the industry faces if the algorithm
favors regular uploads and consistent
clicks and that's across all of them you
know that content creators know that you
can't really disappear undercover for
months and expect to gain any traction
when you break your silence you're dead
according to the algorithm you don't
exist even more depending on the people
that you may be exposing right at best
the big platforms won't cover it and
media outlets and most likely they'll
actively try to bury it because the
enemies of our country their pockets Run
Deep
that's a fact that we have to face
but so does our will your will and so
because this is about a whole lot more
than just business uh I'm very excited
today to announce our first full-time
investigative unit mug Club Undercover
[Applause]
them down here
I have 10 years
[Music]
which means commercial
s
are there children in there I haven't
been in there I do not think so
[Music]
anything
else
for selling us your own leads and
stories which will be protected with
iron cladding we have set up an encrypt
and Hitler at lwc tips
you have his text and you have
confirmation photographic confirmation
that he was at a place where he would
have been with his dad that in and of
itself does open you up to a national
security issue so this is the problem is
the law enforced equally I'm not trying
to like be a provocateur I'm just trying
to get a real answer because they never
give a real answer
oh
how do you thread that needle of
inclusivity being welcoming while also
stopping some fentanyl
you will never surrender our sources
[Music]
a little scarier than I intended but you
know we're not gonna kill anybody just
to be
here
[Music]
so uh we have the mug Club undercover
investigative journalism unit we have
Brian Collins special his new show and
of course you already have our show you
have Nick dipal you have the Friday show
all this stuff at Mud Club
guns and gear of course who's been thank
God he was a consultant because that
would have been wildly unsafe that day
at the range heat stroke and automatic
weapons legal the next uh Creator
announcement what can I say about these
guys
and this is also the story today if you
look at Nick and you look at Brian and
you look at our show
um you look at Mr guns in gear
it's from the bottom up
no one told you that these are the guys
you should be paying attention to these
are people who built this over the Long
Haul they had to play the long game and
it's a lot harder too so these next guys
they didn't come through this
with a non-profit they're backing they
weren't built by a conservative
billionaire they weren't even political
they were just massively popular
YouTubers in the bodybuilding Community
when YouTube was really just getting
started
I was a fan and so I invited them on the
show as guests and on that very show we
not only found out that we shared values
but the world literally found out for
the first time that they voted for Mitt
Romney because they were just that
disappointed with Barack Obama
as black twins
so that began their journey and as they
began to speak out more they were
penalized more videos were demonetized
social media was throttled they were
Shadow bent but something else changed
Their audience suddenly their live shows
were filled with people who were there
not just to laugh but who had their
backs and that really is one of the
beautiful things about mug Club no
matter how much the enemy tries to
create cracks we have each other's backs
here and we know that you have ours and
we're incredibly grateful we'd much
rather owe you a favor
than big Tech or some sponsors that's
why we keep it limited this is again the
organic story of already successful men
who transformed their priorities right
in front of your eyes
from the bottom up not the top down and
I think their transition could be
considered complete at this point when
they started using the username
conservative twins
so now with no more patreon no more tip
jars and that's a big part of Mud Club
too I think a lot of people have tip jar
fatigue this patreon this tip jar and
you want to support people but it's
tough to do because everyone is there
with their hand out because they have to
make a living well here at mug Club
these people get to make the same living
they get to leave whenever they want
because we want to be a family we want
to trust in each other but you
get one place with more bang for your
buck so now these guys no more patreon
tip jars I don't know what they're using
anymore if it's striped they'll be
banned soon uh they're going to be
exclusively members of the mug Club Army
and their show is launching October 1st
a full weekly show for the first time
Hodgetwins uncensored they couldn't be
here today so I give you the Reel of The
Hodgetwins
[Music]
Obama at least the first time right
first time second time mitt Romans yeah
oh wow oh that's surprising because he's
like the whitest guy ever he's a little
scared being falsely accused rape
than ever because YouTube has become a
liberal hoe
[Music]
and by the way there's a video that
they'll be releasing on uh social
regarding uh their new show and what can
you can expect from them here at mug
club and frankly we don't entirely know
it's gonna be good yeah I mean they do
everything together they live in a
duplex next to each other they go to the
bathroom together when they're here in
the studio but they're gentlemen
it's not a joke
so
if comedy specials uh we have new shows
the investigative unit which we've
discussed and again you get a free shirt
at a lot of credit.com but we have
another announcement to make uh
regarding a new acquisition uh here and
by the way I'll be taking your chats
here after this we'll be taking some
questions from the Press so you can send
your chats in right now on Mud Club and
uh we'll be releasing more information
regarding some of the developments but
this is one that we're all
pretty excited about and again if it was
just business it wouldn't make sense
[Laughter]
and who was removed from the platforms
of Apple Spotify Google Facebook meta X
whatever the hell it is uh all on the
same day but there's no coordination
it's just coincidence
and they were by the way many people
back then you said well that's just him
he's too extreme that's just an isolated
case it won't happen to me well
are you paying attention now
and so people who we all expect
to stand in a line of fire who are
supposed to be brothers in arms
tucked tail and ran
they struck plea Bargains with the
platforms who for a period of time would
punish anyone who even hosted him
as a guest
this is the canary in the coal mine
these people at these big Tech platforms
they tell you that they'll never come
for you that you can keep your tens of
millions in revenue or millions that you
make from their platforms and really all
that means is that if you're lucky
really lucky they'll kill you last
well they tried to kill this next man
first
and if he's honest he'll tell you they
almost did
they did a lot of damage
but if there's one thing you can say
about this man love him or hate him is
that he will fight for this country with
every last breath in his body and he
just won't die
so it's with as much pride that I can
convey and as much Surprise by the way
as you in landing this white whale the
number one draft pick without a doubt
out there that for the first time he
will launch his subscription Network
exclusively under the mug Club umbrella
starting with his new Friday show
on August 18th ladies and gentlemen
I don't like them putting chemicals in
the water they turn the freaking frogs
gay
Hitler took the guns Stalin took the
guns pounded the guns Fidel Castro took
the guns Chavez took the guns
and if you're trying to take our guns
1776 will commence again
[Music]
sticking with Facebook it is one of
several companies today that are
limiting the content of far-right
podcast Infowars Facebook apple and
YouTube have all taken down content from
Jones and his Infowars Channel whenever
I talk about Alex Jones my wife will not
let me into the house until I've been
deloused anyone who believes in Alex
Jones and believes these theories you
really gotta go get help Alex Jones has
been ordered to pay 965 million
[Applause]
look how there's a move to control
information is always been and it ought
to scare people that you've got to move
to indoctrinate the Children of America
if they can get you to be part of a
group an environmentalist or part of
your minority group black Latino and
Indigenous people are suffering and
dying disability dangerous terrorists
throughout our homeland is white
supremacists they'll have their little
tailor-made people that there that are
bought and paid for to claim to be your
leader we're looking at a giant war in
February right now currently that's the
projections
there's an entire agenda afoot to force
the population to undergo different type
of Medical Treatments namely vaccines in
2002 there is a tyrannical organization
calling itself the New World Order
pushing for
worldwide government a cashless Society
if any terrorism comes it's from this
government and if there was an outside
threat like a Bin Laden it was a known
cias in the 80s running the mujahideen
war whose family builds all the military
bases over at Saudi Arabia right now
assistant the board of iridium satellite
he's the boogeyman they need
I've been Shadow Man
I've been called a liar I've been
silenced on virtually every platform
created by man my life has been
threatened repeatedly they've tried to
destroy me but I've survived
that's why I'm joining my club
[Music]
Alex Jones everybody
all right
thank you listen I want to thank
everybody tuning in I'll think about
tuning in right now but I want to be
deadly serious here I've not been this
excited
[Applause]
for more than 10 years used to you know
begging to call my show always a really
busy guy and he's a bit popular forever
and but we kind of knew each other but
as soon as I got the platform he saw as
a threat he said I want you on
immediately the day after when everybody
else was running away including my
friends he was like no this is a danger
to everybody I see what this is and then
again everybody else was shutting down
during the lockdown I didn't he didn't
and so it's that type of instinctive
courage that I really respect to become
good friends the last three or four
years since then I love coming up here I
love the energy let's be clear Info Wars
is going anywhere or Austin operation my
regular show that's on talk radio
everywhere but
we've been talking for years about some
type of collaboration and he had to you
know move from where he was to to
trailblaze and do this and and what's
incredible is it's succeeding but but
here's the key we don't just have the
left and the globalist and big Tech and
the intelligence agencies we now know
that we're censoring and controlling and
suppressing election information and
vaccine information and open border and
human trafficking information fentanyl
info and Afghan withdrawal info
it's the big think tanks that Crowder
alluded to earlier that are so-called
conservative that have billions of
dollars over the last decade to buy and
control the populist nationalist
Common Sense capitalist movement that
this country was founded on the minute
the Apple the world's eye and so we're
not just challenging the left and and
Hollywood and big Tech we're challenging
conservative Inc and they didn't make
sense to some people that weren't you
know clued in or on the inside of what
really goes on six months ago and when
Crowder's making a big deal about the
other big conservative platforms that
are conservative they interface with
YouTube and Facebook and and before
Twitter was sold to musk and literally
sit around in Smoky rooms laughing at
the conservatives and I've been around
it it's disgusting to people that have
authenticity like Stephen Crowder and
this incredible crew this these are real
people no these are real people right
here
Carol Morgan Allen these comedians all
these people have turned down tens of
millions of dollars to tell the truth I
mean there's people out there like Ted
Nugent lost probably a hundred million
dollars last six seven years supporting
Trump it's been in the news just no more
stadiums no more nothing it's over so so
there's not many people like that
probably Ted Nugent over here but but
what I'm getting down to is we need an
independent Network that isn't
controlled and I'm sorry Twitter is
better than some of the other so-called
conservative or Urban platforms but it's
still not even halfway free yeah halfway
free feels better than no free and I'm
not even criticizing Twitter it's just
it's just not free so many really
effective people that expose common to
China and certain owners of Twitter's
connection to it they're all still
censored but not Mud Club and I know the
plan that Crowder has he's told me about
it he's told you a lot about it is to
literally bring on hundreds of providers
and I guess the long term even thousands
and then use the great Folks at Rumble
that really are free and open to
energize this so people always say hey
if you want your own internet why don't
you build it or you want your own
platform build it well it's very hard to
do but he's been able to do it be
Because Of You the mug club members and
that gives him that Independence so you
literally aren't just the tail of the
dog you're the whole shoot matcher the
whole dog the teeth the brain you know
the the feet the guts the heart the
brain the eyes and ears with the
investigative unit and everything you
are this operation and if you get
excited about this it's game over then
you will order listen we came and
founded a new country to get away from
tyranny we weren't perfect but became
the freest greatest thing ever so it's
that the the Israelites left Egypt uh uh
under Ramses II and they've now dug up
all the tablets in the history and
that's a true story it really happened
it's on the Egyptian hieroglyphs as well
so Stephen Crowder and the mug club and
this whole operation is literally
leading everybody out of Egypt and we
don't have to wait 50 years or 40 years
to cross the River Jordan folks we're
doing it right now it's already launched
out of the gate successful that is a
true American success story of
dedication work not backing down and it
challenges the entire system so when
this is successful and it already is but
I mean Super accessible it will then be
the example to all the other big
so-called conservative populist talk
show hosts who don't like serving the
globe let's put her too scared to to
Buck them to let them then have the
courage to follow us so this is true
leadership and history that you're
watching right now today now now here's
another key point if you look at the 40
plus billion in Anheuser-Busch has lost
with the entire debacle uh with Bud
Light that's a great example of us
saying we're going to withdraw support
of people targeting children and
sexualization and this whole
transhumanist movement that's what it is
I mean even you've all know Harari at
the WF says oh this is just the
beginning if you'll accept two men
having a baby you'll accept cyborgs all
the rest of it clones Animal Human
hybrids which is all out in the open now
but instead of just boycotts what about
boycotts and that's what this is folks
you get all these great shows all these
great memberships all these great things
and know that you're part of History
bucking the system American Revolution
1776 worldwide 2.0 so the boycotts are
great pull your money out of the
globalist system but then spend it with
the institutions and organizations
understanding of freedom if
Anheuser-Busch just lost I think the
number I saw last week was 41 billion it
just keeps going up and up 25 market
share in all of their products
think about what would happen if people
spent a billion on mug Club a set of 10
million or whatever because this guy's
putting almost everything back into the
operation because it is about the
excitement of standing up for Liberty
and connecting to our four fathers and
four mothers that created this country
and that's what this is about you know
Stephen kept saying it doesn't make
business sense to not roll over and make
the hundreds of millions assault the
system but wait if the whole country in
the world's gone that money doesn't
matter it makes perfect business sense
because our business is prosperity and
freedom and Justice in Americana 1776
worldwide
yeah
so that's what this is that's what this
is all about so so we've been talking
for you know six months about doing this
and I said well I'm gonna keep him
forwards going the great group we do and
they thought and I said what's your idea
and I had my idea already written down
they said a once a week show build off
that then start building some other
shows and with the funding we get from
this we'll be able to hire back more
reporters do more investigative stuff on
the ground at the border and at
Bilderberg and at Davos at the RNC and
DNC so this is a match made in heaven
everybody needs to tell your friends
your family your neighbors hey you want
a second American Revolution you don't
like what's happening well this is the
group this is the organization that is
the best there is we're not up here
saying you know we're Superman we're up
here saying we have all the answers but
you know what it's it's not bragging
when it's fact people need to recognize
that this operation with Stephen Crowder
and his crew are doing is the best open
freest biggest thing there is in the
world in opposition to the New World
Order and hey you tune into my show
you're gonna get you're gonna get
hardcore analysis and Over the Horizon
information on what the globalists are
planning next that's all I do is study
it it's hardcore don't slit your wrist
after you watch it but the good thing is
you can then tune in to the incredible
amazing you know better than the
nighttime comedy shows live delivery of
these guys and they make it fun and
that's why I like the energy here it's
quite frankly Infowars great crew great
people but it's like you are in a bunker
we've been doing it 20-something years
and it's it's crazy so so it's a breath
of fresh air to just add this family to
what's happening to be part of this
organization and to have the Infowars
crew now you're becoming part of this
organization I'm just blessed and
honored it's incredible and at 11 A.M
just coming up at about an hour from now
I'll do my live show out of the classic
Steven Crowder Studios we're gonna have
these guys in here with us it's so
exciting so 11AM Central infowars.com
forward slash show and band Out video
but I want everybody watching that means
on M4 is everywhere to be part of this
revolutionary act you want resistance
you want somebody to stand up you want
somebody to fight go go now to The Mug
Club Go Now ladies and gentlemen use the
promo codes that are there to get a
month off do it now go to Mud Club take
action because the globalists want war
they will destroy us well guess what we
need to start this fight we don't want
it but if you want to fight you better
believe
here
[Music]
our insurance covers all that liability
right
uh I just again uh because we had to
change uh one of the credit card
processing companies that we use because
of how anti-freedom they are uh we're
not doing them we're giving you the free
t-shirt so Alex was he was very zealous
but you get to fight like hell t-shirt
we can't do the free month right now uh
so uh thank you guys so much we're
really excited about uh Alex of course
band dot video 11 uh Central I guess is
what it is don't miss it we'll be in
there talking about it more he'll be
telling you about his promo codes what
it is that he'll be offering it starts
with this once a week show and then is
going to be growing um with a lot as
things as things unfold so now I know
that we said we would take some
questions from uh the press and
questions from you in chat and to read
them is uh Gerald Morgan I guess as he
volunteers as tribute go to live with
credit.com
everything let me just rattle off what
we went through Hodge twins Brian Callan
doing his show of course you already get
Nick depalo Mr guns in gear right the
programming that we already have is
comedy special you're going to have I
think I already said the Hodge twins uh
undercover investigative unit yeah you
guys get the Friday show a full
additional hour obviously every day who
are already mug club members Alex Jones
uh as well on Friday so we just about
doubled that content and uh lowered the
price from where a mug Club used to be
you know only a year ago so for seven
dollars a month
I uh I think I think it's a good deal
but you know that's just me Mr
old-fashioned
[Laughter]
thank you sir so let's grab some
questions and then uh we gotta get going
because Alex has his show to do all
right I'm going to start off with uh one
of the questions we got sent in from the
Press I'm just going to read it for you
so can you expand on rumbles excuse me
announcement that since March mug Club
already surpassed seven and a half
million in subscriptions with three free
months yeah so you guys know I don't
really like talking numbers or money
because I think it's vulgar
um but uh yeah we look we had no way of
reaching you guys you know we created
mug Club forever
um and so because I know that a lot of
you had signed up before and weren't
able to get new memberships we gave away
three months free right so that five
months includes a lot of people who are
still probably in their second or third
month free and uh yeah we're incredibly
grateful even with that it was a you
know 7.5 million in uh initial
subscribership
um which you know has all been
reinvested into what we're doing here
and is a just the tip of the iceberg so
it can be done it is being done and we
can't thank you enough like Alex said
let's get that to a billion so that
they'll be urinating their little
leftist panties right now I know
there we go baby I wouldn't know what to
do with it but I'll figure it out
there are a few things all right so
another question from the Press so how
is mug Club different from before and
what exactly does Network mean yeah so
this is something that we've talked
about uh let me give you an example for
uh I guess starters so Brian Callan has
done quite a few comedy specials and
obviously Nick depaolo has um I mean
these are guys who are experienced
veterans in the industry he's going to
be doing his next special with us now
there's a problem and I'll get to
exactly how this relates to mug Club in
this industry for example for comedians
out there and it's not one that
conservatives have particularly tried to
solve because there aren't that many
people on the right you know who would
really be doing a viable special so I
understand that but there are some
people there are some people who are
very much worthwhile the problem right
now in the industry with stand-up comedy
is you have this choice to make okay you
can get paid but that means that you go
with a place like Netflix or Max uh used
to be HBO now it's called Max which just
means you get some crappy Discovery
chart week crap which hey suppose alert
it's always a human's fault I've been
watching it this week
uh you had to do that in which case you
lose everything you lose ownership over
everything and you hope that it gets put
in someone's featured list the
alternative is to self-release right you
release it by yourself on YouTube
because you want to reach as many people
as possible now if you're lucky it'll
hit critical mass and a lot of people
will see it on YouTube but you may not
get paid and if you say anything wrong
in those specials right on YouTube by
the way I'm not talking about on a
network but even just on freely
available platforms well you're
throttled you're demonetized you're
Shadow band and you make no money so
we've tried to solve that problem and if
you're a stand-up comic out there
looking to do this we don't even care if
you're left or right you just don't want
to be censored we pay you up front
and we pay you with a portion of the
plays that you get afterwards and we
allow any Creator here any stand-up
comedian to release a long version for
free at will on every platform they want
and then there's an extended version in
mug club and so
the performer the Creator gets what they
need they get to feed their family they
also get to grow Their audience the
audience gets what they want because
they get a full special and mug Club
gets the best
you get what other people don't you get
an extended version so we're not talking
about a click bait algorithm with 30
seconds we're talking about releasing 30
40 minute special in an hour hour 10 for
mug Club it's the way to fill all of
those gaps and allow content creators to
do what they do we all know this how
many meetings have we been in where all
of a sudden an executive comes in and
tells you what you want and then
everyone wonders why everything looks
the same and it's sanitized so that same
thing with stand up is we've looked at a
problem out there and this is something
we've gotten a lot of feedback because I
do not take it lightly like I get it you
know we offer this at a lower price than
our competitors for sure it's very
important to us because I know that
parting with your hard-earned dollar
means something but I also know that
there are other creators out there who
you want to support and we'll have
people say you know I want to join up
but I just joined so and so's club and I
just joined so-so conservatives have a
exactly right and we're obviously we're
not there yet but what we are doing is
no no Alex Jill's going to control the
microphone he's going to control the
microphone so
oh yeah when you have tip fatigue look
we want to get to hundreds of people we
want to get to dozens of people but hey
half a dozen of people who you've
already been watching certainly myself
and Alex and Brian and Nick and Hodgkins
right that's more than any other network
out there on the right or left from the
ground up has ever had now there have
been people where millions of dollars
have been spent to tell you that you
want them these are people who have been
around for a long time it's not hundreds
of creators yet but one portal one
network and you get access to all of it
and hey everyone else out there if you
have to make the choice this is a
problem that a lot of creators face we
know this too they go well hold on a
second if I go with a network one of
these people out there I'll get maybe
more exposure right if I if I say what
they want me to say or if I happen to
kind of you know strike a chord with the
audience but I lose ownership over
everything forever or I go off on my own
create my own tip jar my own patreon
whatever it is whatever service is being
used that day and I make more money
because I get 100 of it and I can feed
my family but I don't benefit from any
exposure our contracts are structured so
that you have your subscribers and if
you want to take them with you you can
and everyone benefits from an overall
Network one portal multiple creators and
we want it to be much larger in the
future
and of course and of course Rumble is
the platform for that rumbles you have
Rumble and then another umbrella they've
specifically helped create for us is mug
club that exists on Rumble uh and then
all the creators there but you can go to
loudest cutter.com and you'll be able to
see any of the shows uh or content that
is in the network yeah and you guys will
see that new layout today we actually
just rolled out new layout review so
when you log in you're gonna see those
videos the most recent one something
that's live that's going to be right
there all of the new shows that we're
adding
um let me because we did by the way we
have heard some of your complaints of
course with where there's that and there
was locals and it was you know because
this thing grew so quickly just to be
clear you guys joined up so quickly that
we had to adapt and we had to grow where
it all exists on Rumble now and it's a
lot closer
um if not right there today to looking
like the network that you would you know
you only don't have to see uh uh
eight-year-olds asses like cuties on
Netflix you know but similar experience
just without the degenerate Evil
all right let's go to one of the chats
here so this is the bottom uh bottom
chat in that first series I'm kind of
skipping around a little bit so they
know which one to pull up so at r3d l so
here's the question were they named by
Elon Musk I don't know yeah it seems
kind of random r3dl given the large
platform you have obtained the new
programs and shows do you intend to
begin to engage politicians and parties
more to influence policy and change the
country
that's a good question
um let me let you in on a little secret
most politicians suck yeah
now we've done the show for and we've
had by the way a lot of people in the
show I mean you know we've had I mean
we've had you could go through the
launch pretty much everyone who's who's
run for significant office really has
been on at some point but we won't have
people on to just hit talking points and
actually uh the night of the debates
which is the one of the primary debates
the date I believe it's uh Wednesday the
23rd so Wednesday the 23rd okay
Wednesday the 23rd when those debates
are going on right Rumble is helping
host that we are going to have a mug
Club booth there
where everyone participating can sit
down in that booth and we can talk with
them but they aren't going to be
softballs they're not going to be the
questions that are handed to them with
the talking points from their people and
so often some of these folks don't
necessarily want to come on the show now
I said under the tutelage of Andrew
Breitbart he always said that politics
is I don't know if it's upstream or
Downstream I think both apply is uh is
Upstream culture is Upstream from
politics and think about what we just
discussed HBO right Max Netflix Hulu uh
YouTube Facebook big Tech the
entertainment industry it's all part of
one Unholy amalgamate if you would take
the power of a senator or a presidential
candidate who's really just running to
sell more books over the power of
Silicon Valley in Hollywood I think you
need a CAT scan and so we will have
politicians on as they serve the people
and if they serve you not to serve them
and their handlers look let me I don't
want to throw anyone under the bus but
you know what let's start with Mitch
McConnell because I'm in a bad mood
Nick Nick and I were talking about this
and Brian right well we were talking
about this either we we're on the road
right and thousands hundreds of
thousands of people just last year alone
anytime I mentioned Mitch McConnell it's
nothing but booze same thing for what
whether it's Paul Ryan Kevin McCarthy
Chris Christie and I go hold on a second
I've not met one Mitch McConnell or
Lindsey Graham fan
not one but these people are always in
positions of power that tells you that
there's a disconnect not just with the
left but with people on the right
because these are it's a coronation a
lot of the time and we will take part in
supporting politicians people who
support our values but first off this is
an Entertainment Network it's not just
political punditry and second they have
to serve you we don't serve them so if
they're okay with those terms hey we
have a booth at the presidential
primaries the debate go on Step Up
absolutely it's going to be fun right
after it you guys will see some of those
candidates come by we've already got
some booked yeah it's going to be a
fantastic for some we need a wide-angle
lens I think we can all guess okay chat
uh so right above that one we've got at
sweet potato 918 patatas you should say
it
um I know you're all excited about the
future of mug Club but which new
development do you foresee making the
largest impact
we're already number one so I think
triple in the audience the 50 million is
good
well no look I will say it's our hype
man yeah Alex
I love it yeah it's deaf comedy Alex uh
you know it's tough I'm really excited
about the investigative journalism unit
I always wonder when you look at these
other companies like wait you have
hundreds of millions of dollars why
don't you do this
everyone should be doing it right if we
really care about it uh that's a big one
and look I will say um I I feel like
there's no Winston I love everyone here
but everyone else is too afraid I will
say with Alex Jones to take that on and
a partnership and we've always tried to
even though I don't agree with Alex and
everything we've talked about that on
air it doesn't matter if they come for
him they can come for all of you and
there has never been a one two and I
don't want to say one two punch because
I don't know if they're they're both
they're both overhand rights with me and
Alex on the same network uh that's
something that really hasn't been done
before and the only reason that it could
happen here is because when you reach
certain levels of of success like Alex
has people who want to dangle the care
don't offer you anything of value
um if if freedom and authenticity really
matters to you so the reason that I say
he's a white whale he's an unbelievable
get is because it means that there's
something here that we do that is
fundamentally different from everyone
else out there and so that with
everything else that we're doing
um I mean I'm excited about all of it
but but that does speak to the fact that
hey I appreciate it means we offer
something that that he wanted to be a
part of myself
foreign
you mentioned the other undercover thing
being a really important and big part of
what we're going to do yeah I just want
people to know like we still love and
support
what he's doing out there we're not
looking to replace that but we have so
many people coming to us with
information that at some point
exactly right so so many of you mud
clubbers out there eyes and ears
everywhere coming to us saying these
things and we just didn't want those
things to fall on deaf ears anymore no
no absolutely right and that's why I
said you know largely dead James O'Keefe
obviously is doing a lot of great work
and you have the Target too yeah he was
um
oh yeah we would love to yeah we we love
James and here's the kind of the big
difference too with
um what we do with the investor this is
what's never really existed before with
the investigative journalism
uh James O'Keefe at least in the past
right A lot of it for example you had
donors
um and that often means that these
donors have specific specific goals they
want to accomplish now I don't mean that
these goals are nefarious at all as a
matter of fact sometimes these donors
right are entirely aligned with freedom
but unless it moves the needle and a
politician is ousted or it's something
that is a huge newsmaker the
investigative journalism does not get
funded and here at mug Club hey guess
what a local drag queen Story Hour where
the person who's heading that up also
happens to be the head of a local school
district that's enough wow we can do
anything and by the way it could just be
interesting informative it doesn't have
to exist on a national scale because you
chip chip away it's a battle of inches
and we can claw for every single one of
those because we don't have to worry
about a donor saying Hey I want to make
sure that the 51st congressional
district is ousted before election time
we don't care we want to serve you and
sometimes that doesn't mean just
political but cultural I mean we're at a
point in this country think about it
where we might be banned or we might be
suspended right now for simply saying
that men and women are a thing there's
investigative journalism there that's
important that may not be funded by
donors and non-profits so we have
pleasure you're going to bring back more
of the Ashby uh change my mind
uh yeah we're working on it we're
working on it we're gonna do so we've
got a lot of really exciting
announcements for super videos and
things like that yes with really quickly
before we move on so if you do have a
tip out there right now let's start
getting them in lwc tips protonmail.com
that's lwc tips protonmail.com okay let
me go back up a little bit here to
another chat about this this actually
relates to hydroman Blue said undercover
investigative journalists this is
exciting I want to help how can we
contribute I think we kind of gave you
the answer right there right so send
your tips in but there's other ways that
people maybe maybe be a little bit more
aware of what's going on maybe
parties to get more people to join there
you go yeah get more eyes and ears out
there that's a great way to do it look
it's a simple equation the more of you
who join up and the more of you who
watch and share that's that's that's
what does it that's it's that simple
right and that's and for us to get you
to do that we need to give you something
that is worth tuning into sharing and
the more that you help with these
stories uh one thing I will say is that
people who are willing to go to jail to
protect their sources
um so uh yeah you this is a big part of
this is crowdsourcing where we have
experts here and people in every major
city but you guys can do a lot to to get
some stories going on uh going on your
your neck of the woods oh I sound like
Al Roker who looks worse
yeah yeah absolutely all right so this
one's towards the bottom a little bit so
it's at willcat03 okay um and we want to
grab two more and then go two more times
after this was it is IT band dot video
because we can't if you say that we'll
get removed from YouTube okay it doesn't
exist what are you talking about video
videos
okay
so we gotta get going because he has to
go use the studio all right
oh my gosh I thought you already got
married yeah we're getting married we're
getting married officially later our
covenant before God is already
recognized all right so one more and
after this one so are you really
protected from getting de-platformed or
is this finally something we the
conservative god-loving Americans can
rely on being here long term basically
is it for real this time Rubble reliable
yeah yeah I can tell you this um well
here's a good example actually for
example when we spoke with some some
people well you know Alex Jones is
already uh you know he does his thing we
go yeah hold on a second uh he's on
you're technically on Rumble right but
but yeah but not really because you
still have to do your thing closed
circuit you were de-platformed
everywhere right and I get it you're
like a battered housewife you were you
were de-platformed right so you don't
trust anybody and I understand that and
so we here in a lot of credit for
example
was on Rumble right we were on Rumble
but in name only we were on YouTube and
we might get a few thousand plays on
Rumble and then it moved to hundreds of
thousands of live viewers that second
honorable and millions of viewers
cumulatively where we get far more of
our viewership on Rumble now Rumble I
think just exceeded six percent of the
video place market share which doesn't
sound like a lot but that is
unprecedented and I can tell you beyond
any shadow of a doubt that you know
these are people who are who are
invested in the cause and they want you
to be able to have a platform they want
you to be able to speak freely and I
tell you what
um we're incredibly so we could be we
could be removed from YouTube this is a
good example though Alex Jones already
is he can now regain it he can be
re-platformed on a better site at a
better place and regain everything that
was lost
yeah you can't you can't I get it yeah
we've definitely had these conversations
with the guys and we can trust the guys
over at Rumble so this is a great place
for us to be all right final question
this one's a little bit more
light-hearted it's one of the first
questions that we actually got so this
is from Ray
ray1776. we muggers know you guys work
hard behind the scenes and during the
break but was there anything you were
able to do to relax on your time away
from being on screen now let me just
preface this a lot of times guys think
we're not on screen so we're not doing
anything and one of the most intense
periods of time that we have is summer
because we're doing summer quote-unquote
break yeah we're doing this we're trying
to sign new talent and get the network
up and running get this announcement
ready to go get the show back get
everything going there's a lot that goes
on but we we do get a tiny brief moment
to get away so were you able to do
anything fun I got uh I got about four
days four week in here I got to yeah
whole days with the family yeah it was
kind of kind of last minute oh yeah well
that was one thing I tried to try to
take my little ones to the splash pad
and the municipality said oh there's a
shortage of water so I took them to
Boiling concrete and steel where they
shut everything else off
don't you have something like in your
neighborhood you're like yeah yeah I
think I do he's like what are you you're
in the middle it's like it's like Mad
Max for crying out loud you're just out
there it's just beams of metal where
water should be emitting and it doesn't
so uh I got a yeah a few days but we
really this was I would say um uh
honestly more intense than even the
surgery that I got this was probably the
most intense break where we did not have
a minute and uh one thing I will say
that I'm incredibly grateful for and
look you've seen this going on uh
everywhere else and I guess if that's
the last question that we're doing
um you can go to loudest cutter.com mug
Club you get the uh you get the uh the
shirt fight like hell shirt if you use
the promo code re-platforming Alex is
going to be doing his show here in a few
minutes
um you know a lot of people here have
been uh under attack uh as we've grown
this and of course the knives really
came out when mug Club had its first
phase that was launched you know with
Rumble um earlier this year and
obviously with someone like Alex Jones
and the announcements we expect them
going forward as well uh but because of
this and being under Fire
you know Gerald knows us to have a very
close I have for a very long time circle
of trust people who have known for an
average of over 20 years Gerald's in it
my friend Johnny Boy my dad
um Tim the Tool Man Who you you see uh
but it's expanded because
um you know pressure creates diamonds
and we have some people here I don't
even know if we want to use their names
but of course I'll just say n m thank
you so much T thank you so much there's
so many people here L uh because I don't
know who we need to keep Anonymous there
are people here who really really
understood what it was that we were
trying to build
um and uh I saw them go into war mode
um and that's not something that a lot
of people will do that's not something
you do for a job that's not something
you do if it's just business and I just
want everyone there right now in the
control room to know uh that it's not
it's not lost on me I'm incredibly
grateful and honestly being able to
expand that Circle and have more people
um who I call brothers in arms and
sisters in arms and Z's and arms and
your guess is as good as mine uh is
something that has been very meaningful
and
thank you so much louder with
crowder.com Slash mug Club you can watch
Nick depalo show still going on right
now but we come back August 14th same
week Alex Jones don't miss it thank you
we're excited
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]